just a short drive outside of las vegas
you can find yourself in mesquite and
enjoy a relaxing vacation destination at
the casablanca casino and resort the
sponsors of today's segment and here to
tell us all about the amenities is
christian adderson christian thanks for
being here
so let's talk about i love the
casablanca i grew up visiting there you
know being a local here in las vegas but
what makes it the perfect summer
destination yeah we've been racking up
some great awards uh over the last
couple last year and we're actually got
a gold reward from the las vegas journal
um gold best destination our steakhouse
got a silver uh catherine stegos got a
silver award golf course got a silver
award and also a silver award for um
best staycation so you know with all
those amenities and the great
hospitality that casablanca offers our
tagline is where how las vegas used to
be so we like to have people come up
really experience a great destination
resort and the cost blog has everything
yeah it kind of transports you in time
but also you guys have updated over the
years and always have something new but
i have a question for you because i grew
up coming to the casablanca with my
family and i always look forward to the
slide at the pool is the slide still
there i can 100 confirm the slide is
still there and operational okay and
the adults and the kids are both
enjoying that still at the pool our pool
is truly an oasis in the desert and you
know when you come to the costa walk
there's so many surprises but the pool
is definitely one of those when you walk
out behind the resort you don't expect
to have such a beautiful pool and a
great water slide to be able to take
advantage of yes i can vouch for that i
remember thinking this is a dream come
true and oasis but my parents were
having just as much fun so i love that
it's perfect for the whole family and
something else that really draws people
out there is obviously the golfing let's
talk a little bit about what you guys
offer and what people you know can
experience out there yeah the our our
winning golf course we own two of them
the casablanca golf club and the palms
golf club um our two great golf course
up there we have six golf courses within
six minutes of the hotel so if you're
going there for a quick weekend getaway
you're playing golf but get to enjoy the
resorts you're just six minutes back of
the casablanca and our casablanca golf
club hosts some of the bigger
championships with the nevada open there
mosquito amateur we also had a u.s open
qualifier tournament there so our golf
courses are fantastic up at the
casablanca yeah you guys always have
something going on and hey if you get
out there early enough it's not too bad
even in the summer right yeah we have
tea time starting at 5 50 in the morning
and we have a great package right now 45
dollars gets you a round of golf a
sleeve of golf balls and then a pass to
our virgin river uh buffet so that's
another great way to go up and
experience all the great amenities we
have at the casablanca well christian
thanks for breaking it all down for us
from the food the golf and of course the
water slide you'll you'll find me there
this summer thanks for coming in and
thank you again to casablanca resort for
sponsoring this segment you can call
1-877 getaway or visit casablanca resort
dot com for more we'll be right back